what's up everyone welcome to Battle
Damage in today's episode we're going to
see how well this Nintendo Game Boy
holds up to our three-round live fire
released in 1989 the Nintendo Gameboy
was notoriously tough but will it stand
up to what we have in store for it
there are three basic tests here on
battle damage drop from a normal height
drop from really high and finally a
random act of complete and utter
destruction and we'll be filming every
moment with our spinning
remote-controlled camera rig all right
let's get all cameras action
still boots up no works say Winchester
yeah yeah twerk action
it looks fine only damage was the
battery component a little tab of broke
works till now then about at all that's
the strike okay
and what better way to test the Gameboy
than with our six six two hundred and
sixty five-pound bodybuilder friend Mike
Foster and his sledgehammer maybe do
don't like all the sledgehammer action
all right that's the end of the show and
if you want this game boy to have not
died in vain think about sharing this
video with your friends and what do you
want us to battle test in our next
episode we'll test anything let us know
down there in the comments or on social
media with the hashtag battle damage
thanks for watching America